good morning John I almost made this
video over on Hanks channel where I've
been goofing off a lot in the last
couple weeks but why not yeah you gave
me permission on Twitter so I'm gonna
goof off here goof goof goof
subscriptions it's a brand new thing and
craze that's sweeping the nation please
subscribe everybody's asking for it over
the last 10 years of YouTube
subscriptions have gotten less important
okay it's the thing that has happened
why has it happened I don't know I'm not
gonna go and see that it's YouTube's
fault subscription seem to be fairly
front and center both on desktop and
mobile experiences even on a channel
like vlogbrothers which is very much
sort of a repeat viewer kind of channel
with a lot of viewers that are very
YouTube savvy views on first-day uploads
are only about 30% from subscriptions
and that goes down to like 15% in the
life of the video so it's it's a big
piece but it's not the biggest piece so
since it's a smaller and shrinking
honestly piece of the pie you'd think
that people would freak out a little bit
less when somebody this person said on
Twitter that their subscription feed was
suddenly not in chronological order I
understand why youtubers are so
protective of this one place that is not
controlled by computers it is controlled
by humans it is the one place left where
we know what's going on I am NOT gonna
go into how this information was
released in a manner that allowed
youtubers to be wildly speculative and
miscommunicate and misconstrue and send
really nice notes to twitch being like
hey what's that I guess actually I'm
gonna do that cuz I just did it but look
the sub feed has problems if you look at
your analytics you can see this this
works best for channels that are able to
upload like a video every single day it
works much less well for people who have
to spend a long time making one video it
also if you've been using YouTube for
any length of time you know that it's a
lot easier psychologically to subscribe
to something than to unsubscribe to
something which leads to people's sub
boxes being often or even usually a dang
mass so many videos hit that box that it
is overwhelming and it's not a good what
they call user experience
I think elect that ultimately I mean I
tried to scroll to the end of the month
in my subscription feed and I just
didn't make it I didn't get there I
couldn't I did not have the patience so
I can see you on the channels that I
have access to analytics for that fewer
impressions and views are coming from
the subscription fee it seems like
people are using it last May
that's because home is getting better or
because the subscription feed is getting
worse and of subscriptions becomes a
product that fewer and fewer people use
this is a bad thing for everyone in
YouTube knows this because it's the only
place left where people are guaranteed
to see the thing that they signed up to
see you can't can't cannot fix that by
breaking whether YouTube's like deeply
viscerally understands this the way the
creators do you created a contract with
us this is how this product works and it
has to work this way there is one place
one place where users are in charge and
they need to be in charge we have to
have that relationship with our
communities that there is one place that
we know they can find our videos one
place where I have to worry about what a
computer thinks that needs to not change
and I'm not saying that there aren't
problems but maybe there are other ways
to solve problems like maybe creating a
space above the feed for an
algorithmically generated what you
missed section but because this problem
is so hard to solve maybe it's not a
problem that needs to be solved with
computer code maybe it's a behavioral
problem so to the people listening out
there please unsubscribe find the things
that you don't watch the things that are
cluttering up your sub feed the things
that make it a less good experience for
you and get them out of there it's okay
you're not gonna hurt my feelings and
you do maybe give people more options
for how to customize that experience
because if you want people to have a
personalized experience maybe the person
personalizing it should be a person
because even if fewer people use it the
ones who do are your power users they're
kind of the ones that matter the most
people having some amount of direct
control over their experience of this
platform and over the relationship
between creator and audience sad is
always gonna be more important than
creating the most clickable feed John
I'll see you on Tuesday I made a video
diving fairly deep into the analytics of
the sub feed over on Hanks channel if
you want to go watch that